hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome back to my channel
um you know today's video only talking
about the Delta slash volume the Delta
divided by volume you know there's in a
order flow footprint chart you have the
Delta which is the net difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers you have uh Max Delta which is
how strong aggressive buyers were in the
bar meaning the maximum Delta was to the
positive side you have Min Delta which
is the opposite of Max Delta so it's how
negative or how strong the aggressive
sellers were in a bar at one point
obviously you have cumulative Delta many
of you are familiar with that which is
sort of the running total of Delta
either positive or negative since the
opening of the session and there is
Delta slash volume Delta into volume and
actually this uh topic for today's video
came from one of the comments right uh
the panker who's I've been using my
software for a few years
um hi Mike I've used your software for a
few years and has changed my trading
career I've requested you please upload
one video for Delta slash volume and
it's more you know in I guess what he
means is
um and how it's used okay so what is
Delta slash volume right here so what
you're gonna see in a bar right every
Bar's got Delta I think there's going to
be positive Delta or negative Delta
every bar is going to have a volume
obviously right
and what you're doing is you're dividing
um that Delta number into the volume
Okay so
calculator here uh really quick so for
example right
um you'll see this bar uh right here in
the middle right it's got Delta of uh
minus 192 right and it's got a volume of
15 30.
right okay so you're taking that
negative 192 into 1530 and it's going to
give you a negative percentage because
the volume sorry the Delta rather is
negative so you want to be looking at it
from an aggressive selling standpoint
that's why there's uh
green
background color then there's red right
red obviously for negative uh green for
positive so you're not looking at
negative volume you're looking at the
fact that the 192 into 1530 is uh 12.55
percent
and it's negative Delta so you know it's
a negative going to be a negative value
and you know again every bar is going to
have a value because every bar is going
to have Delta
every bar is going to have volume
now what we found in our studies over
the years is when it gets above a
certain threshold
that warrants paying attention to as a
Trader right because obviously you know
you're seeing the
Delta number being you know a certain
percentage of the total volume meaning
you know it's think of it as an
imbalance in a way okay it's an
imbalance in the aggressive selling in
the bar or the aggressive bind in a bar
and
what it's going to do right on an order
flow Trader chart is it will highlight
it magenta color if it's negative Delta
right here at the bottom or cyan if it
is
um buying right if it's bullish in a way
okay so if you have a positive Delta of
and you got you see the volume is uh
26.99 that gives you a Delta volume
percentage of
31.46 percent right so it's over my
threshold of 25 now
in the order flows Trader software right
you're just going to scroll down here
find it it's towards the bottom
and you can see the extreme Delta volume
threshold 25 right if I wanted to make
this a higher number say 50 percent
then I would just change this to 50 then
I can change the colors from cyan
for you know to whatever color I want
but I like cyan and magenta that's me if
you are on the go charting platform
you're going to find that under bar
statistics so go to the studies go to
order flow pull up bar statistics and
you're going to see it uh
down here right it says he's got the
Delta sign and percentage so like here's
29.04
right here's 26.72 if it's just red or
green that's just your normal uh order
flow going through in the bar but when
you see a strong number
um something above 25 or below 25 I
guess thinking in the negative sense
then that would be bearish now
let's just uh talk about it a little bit
further now remember right in most
markets you trade it decent volume
however if you're trading thinner
markets you gotta be careful with it
because for example right I know I got
some guys that trade agricultural
markets and I I reinforce this with them
you're going to see bars you're gonna
say oh my gosh it's negative 100 the
buyers only had four contracts trade in
this one minute
um so don't get too excited just on the
value you know take it make sure you're
checking the volume that goes through
um you know I don't know British pound
again
you're seeing some decent volumes go
through you know something in the
hundreds this is a one minute chart and
again it's going to vary based on the
chart you're looking at you know if I'm
looking at this is uh
he Hogs so it's very thin traded Market
but I wanted to show you this on on a
thin Market just you know so you're not
automatically
seduced by you know these very big
numbers but they're big numbers coming
in on very thin volume right in the
e-minis it's not a problem so you got
you know you have decent volume going
through in the e-minis that it's you're
always going to have you know hundreds
or even thousands of of contracts
trading
um in an hour if you were to change so
if you're looking at a very thin Market
you know maybe you want to go to a range
base chart
um where you're getting some decent
volumes and it may uh give you a
you know something better to trade
around right where you're seeing
um you know numbers you know contracts
225 contracts and you've seen it
a Delta volume of minus 29 right things
like that so you don't want to be
focusing in on it
in a thin volume territory you want to
be having decent volume right that I
guess that's the one caveat of it right
but again in most you know in the major
markets e-minis mes
um volume is not never going to be a
problem in terms of Delta volume now
like I said how you want to use these is
you want to focus on them
ideally around turning points right
edges of the market I find you know when
a market is sort of popping out or
bottoming out I want to be looking for
some signs in the order flow that you
know there's aggressive sellers if we're
topping out or aggressive buyers if
we're bottoming it out and it doesn't
mean highs of the days or lows of the
days could be swing highs it could be
swing lows so again this is uh Friday
the 18th let me just go back let's just
sort of Step it back to you know around
the cash open right that's uh you know
when you get the most volume coming into
the market and I'm just sort of looking
in here okay so here right you got a
27.25 down on the bottom here right so I
know the volume is quite strong in terms
of
the
Delta volume I guess okay so the Delta
is minus 1587 the volume itself is 5800
all right but we just sold off from you
know the 73 area down to 60s we just had
a 10 point move
and then the next bar after this bar
with the strong negative Delta volume
comes in okay what are you going to do
well you just had a 10 point move you're
seeing some bearish things come in it's
probably can can the market of course
the market can keep going lower but I
would rather have this Delta volume come
in
either at the swing high or just
afterwards you know rather than after
the market sells off 10 points now you
know if you got short in the next bar
you know technically the market did go
down two points but again you know who's
trading you know for 10 points if
you know you'd want to have something
that's going to give you more capacity
for a bigger trade there's nothing wrong
with two points I mean people scalp the
Dome or whatever you'd be happy with two
full points now not talking two ticks
but two points but at the same time
um you know if you're looking to hold it
a bit longer before it fell over it was
spending a lot of time against you right
so it's not really how you want to trade
it you want to be trading them you know
here we come down into a swing low Okay
negative Delta minus a thousand
um decent volume 800 and then the next
bar comes in the bar after the low is
made
with the
strong Delta volume right that's why
it's colored magenta colored okay and
you get a nice move up from around the
62-ish area you're getting the thin
Prince all the way up to 65 66 okay and
it does pull back
um pulls back sort of into this bar area
where that aggressive bind was before it
works its way back up
um again going sideways in here you get
the nice bar here but again
we're breaking out already here right
we're breaking above 71 which was this
swing high and again we just had this
move from you know this was the original
move but even from the sideways activity
here at you know the the 5960 area and
we're trading you know 70 you know
here's 74 75 so you know it's already a
15 Point move and you get that
did the market go higher yeah it went
higher but that's not sort of the the
context you want to be looking to take
it okay then you get up here right we
got this sort of double top coming in
here at 76 and a quarter
and you got a strong
Delta volume to the negative side minus
33 percent okay what happens Market
starts to sell off a little bit turns
around comes back up
okay stops you out fine I'm fine to live
with that right and then just sort of
wait until you know there's another
opportunity coming in you know not
everything we all like to think of
perfection right Perfection doesn't
exist in the market right there's no
trading system that's 100 and it's funny
because I I get emails from people
um we'll buy an indicator then you know
you know even if it's it's correct you
know 65 percent of the time they're like
that's not good enough okay
um
you know you got to take trades and
context right this is going to give me a
higher in my opinion a higher
probability of a bigger move right so
I'm fine to take this move and get
stopped out and wait for you know the
next bigger move I mean if you took that
one here that came in off this low right
this wouldn't have stopped you out it
would have pulled back you would have
taken some heat for about five six
minutes then it had a nice rally up but
again you want to be taking those trades
you know
the Delta volume one that's coming in at
around swing highs or swing lows
um okay see if there's anything else
here okay so Market starts moving up
here you get another one up here yeah
you know it's coming in around the 70
area this is
okay you know again that that's
borderline you know I like to give it
a little bit closer if if instead of
coming in here if it sort of came in
here I'd be a bit more interested in it
than over here
um but uh you know here's nicer one
right you got this swing low Market sold
off you know from the 85s get down into
the mid 70s 77 then this bar got a nice
uh Delta volume 33.73
okay
starts going up pulls back a little bit
shoots keeps going up right you get your
swing high up here
um so you know you're getting long
somewhere around 80 get up to the 85s
then start coming off one two three four
bars here strong negative uh Delta
volume coming in and again Market has
about a another five point move down
pulls back a bit back down to 75 and
lower get into the swing low down here
one bar two bars later nice Delta volume
down here at the bottom and start
working our way back up again you know
from 73 all the way up to 78s pull back
down to 73 back up into uh the 80s this
time okay so
you know get another swing high up here
strong
Delta volume coming in right off the
high you know somewhere to be selling
the 79 to 80 area
again sells off down to literally down
to 75 pulls back up into the 80s back
down into the 77s
um you know when you get trades like
this say you're getting short off of
um you know this Delta volume in here
the market sells off about you know Five
Points pulls back
around hanging around your entry makes
that other move down
markets in my experience at least in my
trading
um you get that move it pulls back you
get another half-hearted move
um take what you can at this point don't
be expecting Market to sell off Five
Points pull back and sell off again
another five points and go lower I'm
really looking for that move to happen
sooner rather than later
okay
um you know don't don't sit here
thinking oh it's gonna
move Five Points my favor pull back
break even a little bit against me and
then make a move again okay
if
it starts making a move down in here
take it you know in this case it made a
move pulled back made a little bit
smaller move pulled back made another
smaller Movement by this point if you're
not out already in here taking some sort
of profits you know of 0.2 points just
be happy with what you got it Market
just doesn't give you those
opportunities
um
to really you know like
go to your take profit if it hasn't
already right because that aggressive
selling that came in here you're looking
for it to build upon and keep going down
so again
um you know that's the Delta volume take
it in context of the market and again if
you're trading in a thinner Market don't
get seduced by areas of thin volume and
thinking oh my gosh you know this is if
63 percent but it's 400 contracts that's
decent but if it's you know
uh it's quite a thinner bar here for you
um
you know if you're if you're looking at
something like you know 38 contracts and
it's minus 63 percent you know take that
with a great assault understand the
market you're trading now one thing that
you can do right if if you're on a
thinner Market or a different Market you
know marketing doesn't trade necessarily
a lot of size you can move it up to say
you just want to see
oh it was the setting in here right I
got a 25. you can move it all the way up
to you know I don't know 80 okay
this is just going to show me the bars
right where it's at
80 percent here so let's see if there's
anything down here at 80 percent here's
100 69 contracts okay Market went up
here's another 100 but it's at the high
of the day new highs I mean does that
mean the market can't go hot and we can
go higher or gotta sell off well
do you really want to be buying the
highs I mean it really depends on you
know if you're comfortable thinking this
Market has capacity to move higher
um here we made the high of the day
started coming off a little bit here's a
92 percent
um you know Market sold off a little bit
sort of bounced back going sideways
you know then and then but again not
everybody trades uh
Hogs hardly anybody but there are I know
I I have some guys that do trade it
um but let's take a look at I'm just
curious
um
take a look at pawns okay uh if it's set
up
quite High
um and it said at what 80 percent you
know probably not going to get anything
at uh this is the five range chart but
you know there's nothing there at
like a full range actually but at 80
percent there's nothing
um in this market right in thicker
markets it's going to be a struggle to
really get above
um 50 I mean we'll shave it down to 50
and see if there's anything in there uh
scroll down
again this is how you figure out you
know on your Market what's a good level
right I find 25 is good enough for most
markets
um here right right off this low in the
bonds on Friday right this was the low
at on the say 37 bar one two three bars
later at 844 a strong 57.55 I took it
down to 50 from 80 percent
and you see this nice move up
so I mean you could see again you know
here this one's sort of in the middle of
the range this minus 51 percent
again you got to decide you know if you
want to be trading in the middle of the
range or not look at this on Thursday
the day before
sold off came right down got within a
tick of the low and then that aggressive
buying came in so the Delta volume think
of it in terms of aggressive buying it's
another sign
um
and you got to move you got a nice move
from about the 22 area up to the 26 27
area
so again you know keep those comments
coming um you know if there's anything
you want to see a video on
let me know okay and you know because
this whole concept of this video came
from the question from the banker
um so anyone have a great uh rest of
your day and I'll catch you guys on the
next video bye bye